are you a hot mess mom do you have a
hard time keeping your together well
you're in luck we have some brilliant
solutions to help you hack your way
through life wear leggings and t-shirts
to bed so you don't have to change in
the a.m. you're ready for the school run
multitasking is your friend brush your
teeth and check social media while on
the toilet
eat off of paper towels so you don't
have to do the dishes doubles as a
napkin eat while you breastfeed don't
worry about those crumbs yup you can use
it to wipe your hands sure kids waking
you up at the crack of dawn go for it
haven't you forgotten something
deodorant it's okay baby wipes will do
oh and they'll also work for staying
right there you didn't wash your face
baby wipes for that too who has time for
baking not you buy store-bought cupcakes
near the frosting around to look
home-baked forgot to shave your legs
keep a razor in your car oh this kind of
hurts well then you should have got your
[ __ ] together and taking a shower look
never mind
doesn't have that bad sure they always
creeps up it's an unexpected moment so
keep toys in your purse at all times
you've had a long day
assign the boring books to your partner
oh honey give it to Daddy he loves these
really long stories now you're ready to
take on the world and time vanished out
of your life go forth and conquer
you